hi this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today I'm learning more about the 3rd
amendments to the US Constitution which
states that no soldier shall in time of
peace be quartered in any house without
the consent of the owner nor in time of
war but in a manner to be prescribed by
law this amendment clearly draws its
inspiration from the quartering acts
that caused a great deal of tension
between the American colonies in Great
Britain leading up to the American
Revolution but does it have any
relevance to our lives today to learn
more I sought out the help of two
experts Jay Wexler is a professor of law
at Boston University School of Law
specializing in constitutional law and
the Supreme Court glenn reynolds is the
Beauchamp Brogan distinguished professor
of law at the University of Tennessee
College of Law so professor Reynolds why
did the framers feel it was necessary to
put this amendment in the Bill of Rights
well we don't think of a quartering of
troops in people's homes is a very big
issue these days and of course some
people would say that's because the 3rd
amendments worked perfectly if only the
rest of the Bill of Rights worked so
well but it was a big issue for the
framers because it had happened a lot to
the framers the English Civil Wars of
the 17th century were more recent
history and they were their attitudes
were very much shaped by that and the
Stuart Kings in particular used
quartering of troops as a way to punish
towns and areas that they didn't like
the soldiers back then were basically
jail sweepings they they had a tendency
to steal and to rape and to get into
fights even with the people they were
quartered with so it was to have troops
quartered upon a town was a way of sort
of mass punishment and that made the
English rather unhappy and after the
Glorious Revolution they banned the
practice in England but they did not ban
it in the colony
the King had quartered troops in private
homes in the colonies in what became the
United States for a long time before the
Revolution since at least 1670 and as
it's easy to imagine this caused a lot
of tension between the home owners and
the colonies and British troops
and that had got even worse as we found
ourselves in the French and Indian War
in the 1750s and 1760s because nobody
wants the government to put troops in
their house the house is the place where
where people live their most private
lives and to have the government come in
and say here the soldiers are gonna live
here with you now is something that
understandably the colonists were very
worried about and didn't like very much
so things got worse in the 1760s when
England the passed the first quartering
act which basically required the
colonies had to provide barracks for the
Kings troops and there weren't barracks
than the soldiers were authorized to
live in Inns and ale houses and houses
this is right from the act itself
selling rum and brandy and strong water
and then if there weren't enough of
those around they could live in one of
private buildings uninhabited houses and
barns and things like this and that that
requirement resulted in part in the
Stamp Act of 1765 which led then to the
tea party which everybody knows about
and the tea party really made the King
angry after that the the King pass or
the Parliament passed the second quarter
in 1774 which required colonists to
allow the Kings troops to live in their
homes which was of course something that
the colonists absolutely couldn't stand
so when we got our independence it was
one of the the most important goals of
the framers to make sure that this kind
of thing could not happen so what was so
problematic about the possibility of
having a soldier quartered in your home
or multiple soldiers quartered in your
home well so it's almost no particular
like having a houseguest in general but
you know they're not houseguests I mean
the problem is you know troops back then
were not like you know you think of
soldiers today in the American army it's
hard to get into the army you know
people people try to get in the army and
they're told go away your grades aren't
good enough and you're not smart enough
and if you have a criminal record they
don't want you it wasn't like that back
then
warfare was was bloody and awful the
troops stood in masses and hundred yards
from each other and blasted away with
these brown best muskets
actually the most common injury then was
when pieces of the soldier next to you
were driven into you jawbone and stuff
like that so it was pretty nasty in the
discipline that it took to make people
do that was pretty harsh and it wasn't
very appealing to the better sort so
literally a lot of these soldiers were
people who were sent there straight from
jail so they were not very nice people
to have living in your house and they
didn't have a very good attitude when
they did I think they were widely viewed
as being cruel as being unfriendly maybe
even drunk a lot but but it was
certainly not the case that they were
that they were you know making their own
beds and cleaning up after their after
their dinner and such like that so it
was it was they were not guests they
were people who were living in the in
the houses taking liberties you know any
way they wanted and making a basically a
nuisance of themselves for sure so I
mean imagine if some soldier you didn't
know and you didn't invite into your
house was all of a sudden staying in
your living room and then multiply that
by however many soldiers it might be ten
who knows living in your living room
while you're trying to carry out the
daily tasks of your life and talking
with your children and making plans
about dinner and can you imagine how how
offensive that would be and how
problematic that would be to have this
the government's troops hanging out in
your living room it would be pretty
awful so it's no surprise that the
framers I think objected to this and and
put this kind of this amendment into the
Constitution so do you think that the
quartering act of 1774 do you think that
was the straw that broke the camel's
back in the American Revolution was it
that living with soldiers was just so
noxious that it propelled the colonists
over the edge into the revolution well
you know there were a lot of straws that
broke the camel's back so it's hard to
say which one but I think one of the
things that the colonists hated about it
was that they were being subjected to a
rule that didn't apply in England and
you know one of the things they revolted
for remember was they thought they'd
been deprived of what they called the
rights of Englishmen and this was just
another example of the crowd feeling
free to do things in the colonies that
it wouldn't do it
and that sent a signal to the colonists
that you're not as important you're not
full-blown citizens we don't care about
you as much and you don't have the same
rights and I think that was what was
intolerable about it so this seems like
an amendment that has this very specific
historical background but how does this
kind of play forward into the future was
there any danger that there might be
later quartering of soldiers after the
framing of the Constitution well there
was always the risk there was always the
risk that even in the independent United
States that the government might at some
point require homeowners to put up
soldiers and in fact there's some
evidence that during the Civil War this
happened I think the evidence is a
little foggy but there's certainly a
suggestion in the literature that the
Union government required home owners to
put up Union troops and so it could have
been a problem it it's not something
that has that has in fact turned into a
huge issue over time which might say
something about how successful the third
amendment has been in our history but it
was always a risk I think it was never
far from the minds of the framers this
possibility that the government might
decide to put to put its soldiers into
people's private homes I think at the
time of the Revolution and when the
framers were putting together the
Constitution they had a real fear of
standing armies right they didn't want a
standing army in the United States in
fact there wasn't one in the United
States at all a professional army until
after the Civil War I believe and now we
see a standing army a very large
standing army of the United States as
being pretty normal how do you think the
3rd amendment shows how our ideas of
standing armies have changed over time
you know one historian said that our
framers had an almost panic fear of
standing armies and that was based again
on the history of the English Civil Wars
in the 17th century we're standing
armies you know the the tradition was
the king would disarm people he didn't
like and then used the army against them
and that was seen as very bad standing
armies were seen as somebody who was
loyal to who paid them
not to the country I think our army has
had a different trajectory I mean really
we didn't have a large standing here in
the United States on a regular basis
until after World War two
so I think we're just less afraid of it
because our army has been more
professional maybe because we feel like
the Army is more loyal to citizens than
it is to who pays it or maybe because
we've just lost perhaps a vital edge of
paranoia that the framers had has there
ever been a Supreme Court case that
ruled based on the third amendment
there's a single Federal Court of
Appeals case called Engblom against
Carrie where the Federal Court of
Appeals applied the third amendment in a
New York prison riot case where guards
were pushed out of their barracks and
National Guardsmen were put in but the
Supreme Court's never done it but the
Supreme Court has relied on the third of
it in fact one of the most famous cases
of the second half of the 20th century
from the Warren court was Griswold
against Connecticut that was actually a
case striking down laws in its birth
control which was one of the forerunners
to Roe versus Wade and in that case the
Supreme Court was trying to figure out
if the Constitution encompassed us a
right to privacy and justice Douglas
wrote this opinion which which said that
there were kind of penumbra's or
emanations from a variety of the
amendments in the Bill of Rights the
Fourth Amendment the First Amendment and
importantly the third amendment that
suggested that the Constitution does
protect privacy rights to some degree
that was kind of the high point for the
third amendment in Supreme Court history
and even in the cases that followed the
Griswold decision which which found for
example the right to an abortion etc the
court did not rely on that third
Amendment penumbra theory so it was a
one case the Supreme Court cited the
third amendment as being the source of a
sort of enigmatic privacy right other
than that the Supreme Court has really
not touched the third amendment ever so
there's kind of a suggestion of the
right to privacy that goes along with
the third
and also perhaps the fourth amendment do
you think that's the way that the third
amendment is perhaps most relevant to us
now well it could be I mean there's been
some thought that there's been some Law
Review articles and other speculation of
this that for example when the
government installed spyware on your
computer at home that's the equivalent
of quartering troops in your house
because somebody is inside your house
spying on you and breaking your privacy
sort of like having to have a soldier at
home no court tell that as far as I know
but it's not crazy and there have been a
few other cases more on point where
people claim that when police SWAT teams
took over their homes to look down on
the neighbors and such that that was
troop quartering but courts so far said
that's not the same thing since they're
not actually sleeping there one
possibility is to say hey the third
amendment really plays no role it's the
courts don't talk about it nobody really
knows much about what it says and so
it's really not important on the other
hand you could argue and I suggest that
this is probably a plausible argument
that in fact the third amendment has
done a lot the fact that you don't see
cases about quartering of troops may
very well indicate how well the third
amendment is serving it so the third
amendment just is is is quiet but that's
because it's doing its job so well and
that nobody comes and tries to quarter
troops in there in anybody's houses and
if they did they would immediately lose
so you could argue a from that
perspective that the third amendment is
one of the most powerful and well
working amendments that we have in the
Constitution one thing that's
interesting about constitutional history
is that sometimes we see parts of the
Constitution that have been dormant for
a really long time
all of a sudden pop up into
consciousness either because the courts
have start reading them differently or
because the facts of the world change
and so all of a sudden that amendment or
other constitutional provision seems
relevant and that could potentially
happen with the third amendment and what
I would cite here are two developments
in the world one is that the we've see
these days the police becoming more
militarized and so it looks kind of like
the police are soldiers in a way when
they come all arms and
they're in armored vehicles and such and
the second phenomenon is under the
increased surveillance that we're seeing
from the government into private and to
private phone conversations private
computer files and things like that and
so it's possible that we a court at some
point might think that the the
government is violating if not this the
letter this then the spirit of the third
amendment by basically engaging in the
twenty-first century version of
quartering by monitoring people's
people's communications within the home
in a kind of militaristic way so we've
learned that the third amendment
prevents the government from quartering
soldiers in the homes of American
citizens and that in fact it does such a
good job the Supreme Court has only made
one decision using the third amendment
as its primary basis but the third
amendment implied guarantee of privacy
in the home may come to be more
important as we debate the limits of
government surveillance of our computers
to learn more about the third amendment
visit the National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution and Khan
Academy's resources on US government and
politics